hey guys Ryan right here hey guys I
wanna go here we're gonna watch a little
trailer today for a film called the
Battle of five armies have you seen them
the desolation of smaug yes
smog it's nice it's Maggie isn't it I
used to see smog and everyone kept
correcting me well they're wrong we're
right right right like come on
oh yeah I forget that I loved it because
Benedict Cumberbatch's the voice of the
dragon enough it made me wanna like [__]
the dragon yeah [__] the magic dragon
yeah we're gonna watch we're gonna watch
this trailer yeah I love the way the
second Hobbit ended even though that's
pretty iffy with a lot of people I
thought it was a cool cliffhanger so
yeah let's check this out alright that's
how you
who never remember remember everything
that happened look good the bad those
who survived and those that did not miss
behind the world ahead there are many
paths to tread through shadow to the
edge of night
[Music]
and shadow
Wow
will you have peace or war
well you follow me
[Music]
one last time
I have a lot of goosebumps right now
yeah I have a lot of goosebumps right
nipple erect okay
I loved how they put that really like
sad song in with the epicly yeah it was
very moving song yeah the whole trailer
was very moving it looks it looks like
this is gonna like really connect like
the Lord of the Rings when the Hobbit
yeah
because from my understanding most of
the third one is made up I believe the
second one I believe the book pretty
much ends with smoke smog smile of
approval Smaug said you pretty much
destroys the I mean whatever happens
whatever the dragon sequences I forgot
and then it pretty much ends there so
I'm assuming most of this is made up but
it looks like Lord of the Rings again
you know like The Hobbit it wasn't a big
fan of Hobbit desolation of Smaug loved
and this one looks like okay this is
gonna I think it'll be pretty it'd be
cool to see more as Sauron 2 because in
the last one he became like a human or
something yeah was weird I have a
feeling if this one's really good it'll
make watching all six really good you
know like it'll make it a great marathon
anyway thanks guys for telling us that
trailer was out yeah if you're new to
the channel if he able to scribe to
Sally's channel I'm the knight he said
hey Ryan can I have a shout out please
you did [__] bro if you're the knight
what does that make me I'm the queen you
always know how to demo me well you know
sometimes the peasant boy gets the Queen
in some movies Oh lovely salamander okay
if we were just only a touch of your
hand would make my heart melt like a
volcano in the Sun there that's actual
quote of Shakespeare I don't know
because plasma technically is its own
state of matter and plasma doesn't know
so I do know a lot about this stuff and
you are right you're right yeah I
remember all that well I'm the knight
you continue protecting us you are a
savior almost people because God Jesus
Gandhi Mother Teresa
mm-hmm Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie oh
boy and then you zc1 zcc one okay I want
a shout out because emoji like that the
real Ryan right he loved to hear you
talking okay
CCC one what are you number one - what
is his ECC zebra Cobra [__] half zebra
[Laughter]
but shout out to you
Braden Alberta huh huh I'll birdie Oh
c'était yeah Braden Alberti how about a
shout-out well how about a shadow
about it what about it what about it
what about this wrong about it I mean is
there something specific earlier you've
got you got your shoutout
you got your shot may even realize we're
shining the fly that just flew past the
camera for you buddy is holding a little
sign that said ba could be your initials
ba Bay I don't know where I'm going with
this have nothing no material prepared
this is what happens when you improvise
everything sometimes you run I had jokes
what do you want from me Braden fly
those [__] in the next room we're
making a lot of no all I heard she's
gonna die sorry I have Veronica hmm
maybe maybe you can like break a fortune
cookie with the fly and then you guys
will switch bodies and you could be a
fly breaking fortune cookie well I can
like in that movie with Jamie Lee Curtis
and Lindsay Lohan they hit their heads
that's well I mean I guess it's kind of
I thought it was the fortune cookie kind
of yeah that was a weird movie yeah
anyway you can't even break a fortune
cookie with a fly doesn't have enough
strength to do it really you know anyway
Braden this was a successful shout out
yes yes fly or do you loud and clear